get out welcome to podcast Ville the
Church of what's happening now is
brought to you by E Harmony let me
explain something to you forget about
Valentine's Day and all that stuff
you're lonely you work too much
you know what everybody's gonna go hang
out in a bar and wait for mrs. Wright if
she's mrs. Wright she wouldn't be in a
bar I mean if you're trying online
dating chances are you're running too
lazy text messages dead in conversations
and random matches that don't turn into
nothing you can't get to know someone by
looking at their picture you know they
dumped these pictures up these days
people trying to meet people I mean we
single he's trying to meet people he's
been in the army the last couple nights
connecting with somebody in there I mean
it's that easy you're lonely how much
longer can you be you're ready to meet
somebody you're ready to get out there
and eat harmony has what it takes
it's unlike any other online dating site
they take steps to other dating sites
don't take in order to find your more
compatible match but listen stop waiting
start your journey to a satisfying
meaningful relationship it could be fun
to play around with online dating app
but when you're ready to fall in love
truly fall in love with someone and have
a meaningful relationship there's one up
that's built to bring real love that's
he harmony come see how he harmony can
change your life go to he harmony calm
and get started
you're ready to fall in love he harmony
is the way to go and to my code church
and check out all right
he harmony hub and to church at checkout
okay number two you know me I'm a big
dude but I just went down from an eight
five six to 185 and my Gihon choice is
fuji go to fuji sports calm right now
and check out a selection of your big
guy people tug on me from the guard they
pull on me they try to pull me down that
[ __ ] thing is the gear debt go to
fuji sports calm right now press in
church bad and get 10% off your order
right that's how I roll number two you
know
me you got to stay healthy look at this
kidiot he looks beautiful he stopped
smoking his skin color he's back to
being natural you know when you're
blacking your smoke cigarettes you get
that shady black you don't have that no
more his skin is radiant understand me I
watch Soul Train thing is I knew what
brothers were smoking and what brothers
weren't smoking those damn camera hits
your face anyway you want to be healthy
you gotta holla holla calm right now
and press in charge and get 10% off on
your first oil delivered to your house
nothing beats that out for brain check
this [ __ ] muley favorite turn
sweet darling BB in the [ __ ] house
without go what's up baby boy you look
beautiful thank you handsome chillin man
I don't know you gain weight you don't
look I mean stop smoking cigarettes oh
they already say you gain will you set
smoke cigarette cuz I mean eating like a
[ __ ] hungry you don't look I
mean in the morning I remember I used to
wake up in the morning first thing I do
is smoke cigarette you know and I
wouldn't probably have a coffee you know
I probably wouldn't eat that's what you
like much drinking coffee with that
cigarette I smoke I'm now somewhat we
with it now you know I just replace
their attendance place to say yeah
that's way more we now yeah you smoked a
ton of weed there's no I got off the
cigarettes I got to say it was [ __ ]
weed though I didn't like the patch I
love that [ __ ] actually made me break
out I tried it yeah I may not break out
of make me all itchy and stuff but yeah
what's going on with you Lee say it I'm
doing good everything all right yeah
everything's been going great it's uh
did the couple but Mike last night I'm
really enjoying [ __ ] with you leak
that's right where were you huh as Sam
trip please room no reason Austin oh
that's right
I came with my church folk yeah a nice
time was good that was with the Papa
dose no I'm saying I'm really all over
that bread right now [ __ ] egg bread put
20 pounds on your ass man Texas is scary
like this is cosine to be fair you know
what I don't it don't matter what other
taxes you know that you'll find [ __ ]
something something like I just want to
god it's the weirdest thing what I mean
tumblin like food right yeah I some day
you are you live there going Jesus [ __ ]
give me too much food you know for 10
bucks that was a big [ __ ] breakfast
something bigger in takes I'll Paso
place to go nope a so there was a
supermarket on the corner I would stay
in the condo and I would be excited
because [ __ ] 60 yards away they had a
place that made food every day
plus they made two soups homemade ain't
talking about cream and chicken noodle
no no no no they would make exotic [ __ ]
Oh dividers hate it you're like damn but
on Fridays they made you could take fish
soup and I would get all coked up on
Thursday night cuz I knew I'd be
straight once I had that fish soup oh my
god
this [ __ ] was still [ __ ] gonna die by
the gallon am I gonna eat it all day all
[ __ ] down with either from that
supermarket yeah you know you always
found something there was always
something taxes Cutler Texas move I dig
it I always have I'd never say we loves
a little different oh yeah is that
though it still is illegal no I just I
don't mess with Texas that's all I know
right I'm going again come on vacation
leave on probation do you guys get
worried about cuz look when I was
driving across country my mom was like
be careful you're Jewish be careful
where you stop and I mean I never heard
anyone look at me anyway but like like
being black and being Hispanic is a
little bit more obvious than it is to be
a Jew I can hide like I mean do you get
scared Danny I mean yeah when you're
doing wrong
when I was a kid we do all type of while
[ __ ] yeah you know like that pisses me
off and I read in the paper you you
pulled snoop over at the airport you had
an ounce of weed wow you're a [ __ ]
secret agent [ __ ] secret agent you
know there's some people that the
obviously you pass to have a problem
traveling more there's somebody win a
prize so connect now as soon as he
touched down there where'd he go he got
somebody already got it but he ain't got
that Kelly Buddy Holly what do they
check private planes or can you just
know you want to do whatever the [ __ ]
you wanna drop a chick if you throw a
chick off a plane on tour like you know
when you always go through Arizona you
got to tighten it all up
could they pull your bus over in a
heartbeat so everything every time you
go through Arizona we make sure when we
got here that's crazy
that Sheriff was pretty intense there
yeah I mean you don't get locked up in
the beating of pants and wearing that
pink [ __ ] [ __ ] that matters on a scary
place man
yes sir that I can't be you know but I
guess everything's about to be changed
mean we love this loosening up and you
know about to be dispensaries everywhere
man next ten years man this [ __ ] about
to be lit yeah I don't even know the
change like I've been talking about this
for three days I haven't seen no change
I'm still getting [ __ ] higher-power
[ __ ] yo said the one place I know that
they buy the book now they ain't nothing
then passing day by the book I mean it's
[ __ ] crazy
dead by dead down to bare bones so I'm
gonna be able to go there twice
Denver is my only message edibles out
there no I don't mess where I don't even
go to a weed store this time in Denver
no Dean Colorado I'm and missed him at
Thursday night's show I know he growing
to pile of the weedy doesn't have his
regulated he's just growing it out in
the mound
Denver outside so he's his is probably
higher than anything we get yeah you
know I didn't see him flowers per I
always bring my own I don't want no
misunderstandings that songs in Denver
had some bacon there's like brown sugar
and all that but it was like a 200
milligrams of strip I she [ __ ] me yeah
but he [ __ ] my stomach on to know
better I got smoking the blood I wasn't
a fan of mushrooms for years because
when I went to Colorado in 83 I was an
acid dude mm-hmm
I went to Colorado pick my wing I'm
gonna ask her we got mushrooms and one
fourth of July by myself I started blast
them and there was a little bridges just
at a little four foot bridge to make it
seem like something my mushroom mind I
went over by the bridge and I just sat
that was 18 years old my roommate went
away with his girlfriend for a week and
then we can't but I don't Condor to
myself and I'm sitting that [ __ ]
original Wow
I can't believe I got out of New Jersey
I can't believe I don't do that crazy
[ __ ] no more and the next thing you know
I was having a good time I had diarrhea
like a [ __ ] I had a run home I
think I [ __ ] my pants oh my god and I'll
never forget but I like the high but
they definitely got me [ __ ] see like
I was sick that night like diarrhea
diarrhea I'm only a couple months later
I do me guess it was just a symptom of
it and people will tell me that they
will have the same reaction I try them
in a cap so now nothing happened yeah I
don't think threw down nothing now I'll
blast a mushroom farm when I get home
mushroom in the air we ate a little
[ __ ] there I'm cool what about when
you eat edibles and your [ __ ] or your
bacon how much you smell like a book
yeah
got Dennis you don't like the food I
know I'm not that there was one dude one
time dog but I would turn you onto him
he was the sample and Cisco a chef I
think it was a hundred a head he comes
over and cooks like our five or six
course meal free hmm and everything's
got ta said yes or the salad the salad
dressing got th sailor sir yeah but if
that's a thing of something they really
like a tasty thing at this piano or
anything
I talk about that thank you I can taste
I mean if you like put in a certain food
I don't think it tastes good like we
mashed potatoes I think you could maybe
like mask it and food like that's why I
don't like like with the tribe I mean
you can mask it real good and yeah but
I'll tell you what I would do if I had
the time and the money and the energy
you know what I would love to make the
hc1 salsa de pollo sauce
no without the jalapenos would take that
flavor see how good is maximum cheese
burrito my brother the Denver I want him
to get on stage or that I didn't want to
shock his system and put him up there
six lines me but the main reason why I
know he loves food I love this dude
because I know he loves food and we went
to Sam's number three he's got the green
chili dog this [ __ ] got a
hamburger that dog if he wasn't I got
control I thought it was beautiful what
color and cheese but it was a Mexican
winner was a Mexican [ __ ] hamburger
tortilla with being smothered beans dog
I'm a fat [ __ ]
Oh Sherman takin [ __ ] burrito he'll
[ __ ] uh uh
that's his [ __ ] I used to eat what do
you it was delicious
then I could see his face when he was
eating the fries oh you know why he was
16 I could see him he was looking into
the ceiling like a half a mo mo thinking
like this is the best I've had in my
life no Blair I go lead dip the French
fry in the green chili boil it you
shoulda seen this little face I didn't
even like at first cuz to be fair we get
picked up early I get inedible and we
get on this flight we what do we do
we've to hold no Peter yeah we split it
I think I think we split one at 6:00 in
the morning or whatever it was but like
the amount of hunger I have by the time
I get to Sam's number three on you and
then I didn't even order chili remember
when we except fresh that down I didn't
you ordered chili and you got you're
like where's yours because I got that
big ass partner with green chili on it
you're like no you need to get a cup
right now so I'm gonna got a cup oh dude
it was I I think I don't go there every
I think I had like one meal somewhere
else but every other meal was there yeah
I said the hotel right around corner
from there so I'd be good Oh every time
I'm up there I love those kind of bars
like there's like food bars oh yeah I'm
sure they do yeah we read the menu and
I'm sorry I forget the guide their first
names but on Friday morning or Saturday
morning forget which one I was sitting
at the counter and these two listeners
came up and were like hey great to meet
you if you'd like to come have breakfast
with us we're right over here and I
would normally would always say no for
that mm-hmm just because I'm a shy
person but I look at the damn rules and
it was it was very cool this one guy is
from from America I lived in Thailand
now there's something I was in Kansas
City and they met up there to go see you
and it was a and they were in they were
and they were drinking they drinks with
pancakes it's pretty [ __ ] cool that's
crazy
you want to obey me boy nah I'm actually
I'm working on the album right now so I
just don't spot dates right now like I
go the next thing I do I go to Chicago
and then I got a show in Iceland I go
out there for my birthday it's kind of
cool and got the [ __ ] good how long
is the flight Iceland I have no idea
I know I go to Boston and then I fly out
of Boston so what's the longest flight
you're Billa
the right date 25 hours Oh what do you
do you know I get the bed you know when
you can lay down that's crazy
so I could do that but it's expensive
this [ __ ] didn't classy [ __ ] so yeah but
yeah sleep eat that's it I'm so used to
it now it's like [ __ ] hours on a
[ __ ] fly [ __ ] it's terrible I mean
have you done it before coach bad
international flight yeah you definitely
have to takes an expedition if you get
lucky and get like a row to yourself you
know I'm saying the most I don't like
too much to make it happen but I just
recently did it I mean I'm with
Australia for New Year's
I'm not flew out there not did like two
days if you write back home it was like
I can't remember like I spent more time
in the air than I spent in Australia I'm
good for six hours I can entertain
myself from here in New York City
computer doctor funny and they always
have one movie you know oh yeah you
watch out I've been to so many
I don't watch every last movie on that
[ __ ] program yeah let's let if
you fly them in left let's say you take
doubt to the same month it's the same
taking flights and out there and you
take it the first week of the month in
the last week of the month it's the same
featured [ __ ] movie it's which ever
but there's always a Tom Cruise will be
like this
there's always something that but lately
they've been getting [ __ ] up on this
lately there's a couple Airlines United
Americans on those long flights they
give you dick for real bro they give you
dick even first you pay for it right no
you just does not take there's nothing
I'm not I had to have me be Delta no not
a doctor but I've have seen that a few
times don't like this would find a
little too long we don't got no TV yes
because you just certain flight you just
expected you know but I've gotten on the
plane of disappointed yeah if I'm a
valued member and I got an upgrade and
it's and the dog this happens all the
[ __ ] time I'm very thankful but at
the same time I sit there I go for hours
no I mean they can always have like the
ones when I started flying they have
like every few rows would have a TV and
movies would have like a projector so
leaning by like the your phone so least
you can have that listen to something
just play the game and everything I fly
a lot you [ __ ] love you expect
certain things you expect delays you
expect whatever you know what man the
last eight years or what have I learned
how to fly when I was on the road were
broken he used to just not [ __ ] with
like Melissa I'm doing in the
first-class tickets my head would blow
up I'm waking up my feet Jacqueline in
first-class as long as I blocked him he
would take the window yeah nobody would
bother yes he was on fear factor but it
was weird I thought when he travelled so
I learned so all those years I was
getting points on American okay he took
Ari to Australia he was platinum oh my
god
so I fly you know I'm high with American
I'm high with whatever you know what man
when I go to New York from here and back
it's always your blue minute huh that's
my [ __ ] now how did you Delta has been
I love Delta - I gotta call Delta
tonight and cancel a flight and
reschedule one when done I believe
Wednesday night to go down to [ __ ]
Albuquerque New Mexico is [ __ ] next
month like April 4th and 5th
I'm gonna do the Jackson wing podcast
when I'm down there yeah
Joe Romero has been confirmed I'm just
gonna drop it on yeah I'm not gonna tell
you what that's how I roll [ __ ] yeah
it's just gonna be a [ __ ] tweet on
your periscope and your romero be here
and the next day's Dylan Rogan podcast
will kwazy we're gonna do a Spanglish
podcast which is gonna be very
interesting that's tremendous man that
last fight was crazy seemed like God is
God all the time they don't listen you
come off there's a lot of stuff you say
in the beginning that you don't know
what you're saying
like something like I told you guys
maybe five I lived in San Francisco my
mother died in 79 and 85 I won on the
land to San Francisco and I walked into
the Tenderloin and I see all these
Cubans and I became friends of these
Cubans and I learned about that struggle
and why they came over here but the
interesting thing was but they were out
there slinging it mm-hmm
and the one guy this is exactly what he
would say okay when people weren't
buying white people he would look at the
monoi body wanna for Sally Sally body
wonderful salad I get it people yeah
yeah I won their phone they said wait
what are you saying to these people
it will go money wonderful Sally and
then what Sally he got and he spelled
before misael mm-hmm but in Spanish this
is Sally
mmm so he kept saying muddy wonderful
Sally it's not for Sally it's for sale
you [ __ ] me that's crazy
this guy went four years with that
pronunciation that I'm really [ __ ]
though I really and I knew that growing
up how Cubans turn [ __ ] around with
their word okay in a funny way when they
try them that's not mine my stepfather
you like broken English my stepfather
spoke great Spanish but when I spoke
English it sounded terrible and when as
I got old though my friends would come
over he would try to be cool mm-hmm hey
mother focus it would sound so horrible
how he said it
Hey more than four pasta yeah well yeah
you know my mother knew that I don't
know how the [ __ ] she knew this probably
you know I moved north Bergman when I
was 10 so when I was 12 my neighborhood
on that block was predominantly Italian
Johnson Adi
the Clements is mr. t no Cathy Ortiz and
Valentin live next to me the people next
to me really O'Rourke's the people next
to them were the the especially al who
were Sicilians and her people next to
them will the [ __ ] hit me whatever
the [ __ ] that his dog his teeth were all
chiseled to the bone because he would
chase rocks what you would throw a rock
up to him he would real he would chew on
rocks he was a big dog that was
beautiful but for some reason to me
whatever dog he had a this kids with
Timmy from 55 Timmy's probably because
when how is [ __ ] 13 timmy was about
sense and Timmy was a beautiful aboard
who had this dog when I'm with no leash
it was a different time that's this
correct I'm talking about this is 99
rise and he would throw rocks for him
every day
and the dog would [ __ ] pick up and
bring it to me the dog would never bite
[ __ ] up like that and let's the father
had chickens
his father was joke but he was a solid
dude I don't remember his mother but he
had an older brother who was out there
dog was a must as don't run this is the
time we were kids
Yeah right and he was tough to boot he
turned out to become a heroine do it how
even know where he is I think he died
but we were like 13 or 12 we used to go
to the woods in the summer and we heard
some [ __ ]
and we walked up that and there was
Timmy's older brother I can't remember
his name right now [ __ ] a chick both
to the bone ass naked out in the open
with a blank in the hole like they dug a
hole to try to go unto the hole that's
where I got the idea for the time when I
took that chick home how she left me
finger and then she told me she was
gonna let me [ __ ] on his [ __ ] and the
next night is snow and I built a little
[ __ ] they glued it that's why I stole
the idea from it for their company when
I was [ __ ] they was his brother
because his brother ding like a transfer
you couldn't see him like he was a
paratrooper behind him from airplanes
and [ __ ] there was a soccer field up
there so it was like this slanted got a
walk through shrubbery and [ __ ] so we
went up set we caught him [ __ ] we
heard him [ __ ] and we walked up to
the top right we were kid this is the
fresh he had a hairy [ __ ]
her name was angel she had a sister
there were one two sisters that didn't
go to my school they went to a school
called Frank on the school and there
were two sisters you know one year old
and the other both of them
I forgot what their name with talent you
know those dark Italians beautiful yeah
this chick bone has naked outside
[ __ ] her so well up there watching it
our faces are all red we had to be
really young because we were like in
shock you never the first time you saw
sex yeah you want to shock but when you
were supposed to see
okay the first time you saw sex that you
weren't supposed to see you've got a
creepy it wasn't a pleasant [ __ ]
experiment you have for you didn't
really understand what the [ __ ] is going
on it was a kid one time there was a
dude that would come to my mother's bar
his name was Arnaud I love them to death
but he would [ __ ] with me when I was a
kid like when I would see everything
goes he's still pissing sweet I think
Laurie at the time I had nose and I
would look I'm like what the [ __ ] yeah
but he would say creepy things to me in
front of my family and everybody would
laugh you know he would ask me if I got
my dick sucked yet I had to be 12 or 13
when I first got like a girlfriend they
went nuts
hmm the people around me would not say
torment to me every time I went to my
mother's bar she's sucking a dick what
are you doing over [ __ ] what's it taste
like
never got occurs when you're nine years
old nor was it eight that was about 12
and the six screws no I meant that girl
but when I got left back over and I saw
the dryer hopefully she told me
something give me a slice then she had
this she reneged on the deal drove uncle
Joey crazy I couldn't study I give it
karate I quit playing basketball
I was a broken man it was the first time
I had ever been in love yeah I'm the
first time you in love yeah his [ __ ]
broken yeah were you I mean same
situation with me I [ __ ] up a school
of a girl and I tried to tell myself it
wasn't really a girl
grab him I was in tenth grade I was
dating a scene she'd caught me at like
Tim gray English assumption is like
because I didn't tell her what grade I
was there you know saying she's like
we're gravy and I remember from that day
I just start skipping class you know
[ __ ] with her and [ __ ] but I've never
even met school really being up there so
I ended up quitting high school cause
the girl but I would try to tell myself
I dropped eyes go to say of drugs in
like that but nah it was over a [ __ ]
girl
mother really stuck with me because I
was in the team grades he found out the
truth eventually you know well yeah so I
was heartbroken over that is like liquor
I fell in love with her probably right
and dog I went the whole thing I went
the whole thing that we went through
when you [ __ ] with Spanish women it's a
different game no sure I know it started
[ __ ] up like I had to stop first I
hung out with a brother but her brother
was older than me and he had a sister
and it turned out that that sister was
down hottest chick in the [ __ ] class
names it and I kinda had a crush on me
you know you look I mean though Jesus
that girl's [ __ ] beautiful
she was Cuban but she looked more French
and [ __ ] now I started hanging out
with him more and more and I started
hanging out with a heart and something I
don't know I just felt I just [ __ ]
got my heart beating [ __ ] so I asked her
go to the movies the grandmother came
that time question yes that burro yeah I
pay for her the grandmother what and
then we went together you wanna impress
Graham where you got a puppy right so I
took them physically away I took him to
the cinema and then we went to carve elf
ice cream and then we went home and we
had her talk to the UM the front porch
for about 20 minutes and then we said
we'll see each other that's how it
started was just just a simple romance
[Laughter]
her and I started rollerskating
okay sorry sound right uncle Joey would
knit over a house with shine shoes and a
brand new a shirt on and we go to
Paramus mall roller skate around to all
the hits mm-hmm you know we do that with
well escape together I was such a
[ __ ] idiot
I was such a [ __ ] can't comprehend I
know if every God beaten up with joy I
was the biggest sucker go and then like
I kissed her we kissed and that was it
like we have like a secret deal her
brother couldn't know mm-hmm but at that
time Donny Osmond was big hard [ __ ] on
Friday night she would always watch
Donny Osmond if she was in love with
that [ __ ] and I would sit there ready to
cry oh we ready to cry because I wanted
to be tortured like [ __ ] Paula I just
want to be tortured listen here and take
this abuse
I always say no no no and I would say no
you didn't go to [ __ ] [ __ ] you didn't
want to say no I got along beats on
Louise
[ __ ] Bobo I would sit there Friday
nights with her and the grandmother and
watch [ __ ] Donny in the read the
torture human-human she would cry how
beautiful he was and I was just a skinny
little [ __ ] dopey kid polyester [ __ ]
and I be sitting there all jealous
and I thought and I'd want to say that
Donny Osmond was a [ __ ] that aids if I
said Danny I was a [ __ ]
you and then I [ __ ] shine like oh
yeah what else you know that when you
have a those molds hmm you have those
fishbowls
okay and she had a fish in there a
couple of fish in there and then when
she got home and of a kid drowned trying
to get to college what the soy I hope to
buried the fish and that's when I got
him with it oh I hope to bury the fish
that I held her and then we held hands
and [ __ ] so from then on for like three
months after school right before we go
to our house we go in a parking garage
and we make out 15 minutes
[ __ ] come all over myself and I go home
all confused this is going on for like
three months and you're like [ __ ] oh my
god then we kind of went on you know we
would talk on the phone all night and
[ __ ] and then we started [ __ ] playing
hooky we didn't have to and going back
to this everything nothing else before
we started playing hooky we just go back
to my house and dry up and try it on dry
dry out took my for cornified
every former [ __ ] my mother go there and
we would dry out hurts when the fire we
would just dry up like a [ __ ]
fire yeah
giannis then we started playing hooky
and then with the same thing I went they
her and I played hookey and we went back
to the house and the mother was waiting
for us I got caught here we got caught
so we weren't allowed to really see each
other I was over it for like a month I
were both punished from each other it
was [ __ ] horrible hours and we
couldn't do homework and quick karate I
stopped watching TV when they thought oh
my god I broke apart on the sames guys
why are you quick writing because I
couldn't even focus I was old so much
lovely I did not know how am I going you
know Bruce Lee had died this was just a
string there haha that wall linked
together like mental destruction as a
teenager and it hit me hard but I said
we just got separated and then we hooked
back up and we had a plan that the last
day of school and by this time so go do
your monkey Doo by this time and all
these I couldn't get myself on there I
don't know he's I think it myself out of
it so the last day of school they didn't
put me in the 8th grade they put me in
the other concepts of grade that means I
had to go to summer school
for the eighth grade and by that time I
didn't give a [ __ ] that's tomorrow
she was gonna give me a piece of [ __ ]
in the next [ __ ] day she relaxed she
said she couldn't do it I can't do it I
want to be a virgin for a little while
longer I still want to dry-hump oh well
you squeeze my tense I mean I wasn't
even sucking to tell you oh my god
that's how much I love my was bro and
then I started going to summer school
but we only tell me to dry out then
because her parents were watching that
and my mother was watching me you know
the only way I could dried up but was
between 10 and 12 every day just to dry
out [ __ ] let's go how is the paper
Simon's good know is free service know
is a free service they make her hate
with something Spooner told I was a love
guys and I failed and I thought because
I knew calm my bowels a know that would
let me skip oh my god they're like that
is not gonna work mr. dog because mister
dawn the one principal came up for me he
ran the summer school program he's a gay
bro you missed three sessions some
you're dying Oh mr. Dalton please this
is something I could do he goes nah
don't when he goes have carmine talk to
you talked to carmine let a man was of
the whole summer I waited till I [ __ ]
two days before school mm-hmm class
somebody knows I can't help he'll you
[ __ ] do [ __ ] up in summer school I
didn't tell my parents not dead and uh I
was ashamed row and by this time
didn't want us to see each other I was
[ __ ] up and I got left back I'm gonna
seventh grade eighth graders were all
looking at me creepy I'm sure you can't
your left back boobs oh my god there was
no therapy in those days and people
would tell me how you doing man you are
you all girl I'm uh I'm Oliver I stopped
eating I went back to karate and you
know what she little fire under my ass
now I started paying attention to school
and then it was funny he is later she
came to me to bail her out a date had
been her and her boyfriend broke up oh
uh before the prom and she knocked on my
door my mother died after my mother died
and she asked me if I could cover the
spread
if I could take it to the prom do her a
favor and she doesn't be doing I'll have
sex with you my tits and she had an
accident it's got big and she just
scared me bro at that time you know my
movies began left-back ain't that stupid
to fall back into your diabolical weapon
dare those from you scroll fan our dog I
might attempt oh no I didn't know no no
no that was no sex machine at anything
but I knew I didn't want to go back to
that dark place that [ __ ] at me
listening to Jermaine Jackson yeah
that's how depressed I was Jermaine let
the Jackson 5 he went solo and I was
[ __ ] down this time over and over them
good down had a song I never knew
Jermaine solos any of you I got another
I see if a YouTube let's go out Lee I
got rain Jackson hold on hold on let me
think of something okay we going through
it so are you taking mushrooms like
nothing you know ain't put on Jermaine
Jackson
I'm looting here let me just check the
sign you're gonna hit Jermaine Jackson
when he went solo dog this is crazy
mr. Jermaine yeah if I had to remain
Jackson that's how that's what I want
Michael Jackson have left the [ __ ]
Jackson 5
this chick [ __ ] dumped me and now
Jermaine look at the playwright look I
look now look at that cut now let's see
oh don't even look real you little
prosthetic what was you listening to one
Jemaine Jackson
so press Jermaine Jack's well as a short
over know what is dynamite put in my my
touch of mad there you go tell your mom
I'm touching man you ever hear this no
here you go here's Jermaine Jackson
coming at you when he broke apart I was
fine touch of madness listened to
Jermaine Jackson you'd think he'd come
here cuz he was dating a sister right
he married beat this daughter and the
daughter the bad girl was gone yeah but
it's natural
yeah
[Music]
are you going through how is shredded
yeah I'll go Joe tortured romantic
[Applause]
[Music]
you like tears in your eyes
this is terrible right now I'm starting
to feel exciting day today people know I
didn't wear it out today I took my wife
I went home after [ __ ] kick box and
they have much going on and a riot and I
said some [ __ ] to some people so I
wanted to care but my wife came back
from yoga school young girl I'm not
really go hungry I go to that place and
get one of those Armand look smoothies
in there it's all fruit and this protein
it's like [ __ ] is six points or I get
the [ __ ] smoothie which is pressed
apple juice mm-hmm and fruit so I'm good
to go hold on oh sorry was one other
thing I wanna go see you there
waswas I listened to at that time that
was it did a Jermaine Jackson oh no you
know I don't think I did that but that's
what Jermaine was putting up that's how
heartbroken I was you gotta you gotta go
through that know everybody got to get
to that what was your first heartbreak
Lee how are we well like it's weird cuz
I don't really have like she was like
she was like kind of like my girlfriend
but not really like we were young like I
was like middle school cuz she left in
high school but she was my neighbor only
like we would take our dogs on walks
like you think it was hard to get me a
walk now I'd be walking every day for
like hours cuz she was cute she was the
first girl let me touch her boobs
knowable and then like I like it was
like god yeah I was weird if miles was
worse with videos with I was with my you
know everybody at a high school
sweetheart you know I was with mine but
we used together all the way like pass
and that was like really like start
making music and I was going in New York
all the time
solidly go to New York to record and I
just remember coming back one time and I
caught her like what's up and she goes
like I'm with my boyfriend like what's
your boyfriend like what the [ __ ]
unless he saw me yes she [ __ ] me up
how old that was was my twenties then so
we were fine we live together all type
of [ __ ] like we had just recently moved
out
no I got my [ __ ] ripped apart in the
seventh grade and then I got my [ __ ]
little tougher mm-hmm and the eighth
graders [ __ ] I started stroking and on
the 8th grade I wanna dig slingin dick
was sucking titties and how I started um
girls okay like I dumped this girl for a
different Irish girl and then I time
swap this prick with her best friend it
was I want to tear it oh my golly think
this one was [ __ ] heart broke I'll
take his word but I can never get a
girlfriend that's a different situation
I would get my little fix everything at
that AIDS I'd always hook up with
somebody we'd make a movie finger in
those days those girls would just grab
your dick from the outside at least I
shot alone in the hand they would never
I would never even dream but taking my
dick out at that age for a woman that
can be Angela I would be embarrassed
like that's how Catholic I was uh they
would rub my dick and I'd be a little
nervous at the district as she sucked
big before I was one of those guys it
was it was really creepy and that
heartbreak for me hmm I will and then
it's I know I got my heart broken again
and 82 in like a weird situation kind of
way 82 83 but it was one of those quick
car days that was like my confidence
would not let me [ __ ] talk to anybody
for four or five weeks just dumped you
yeah we'd stop
I just want to be alone I go to the
movies by myself I need Chinese food by
myself I know what you mean though it
was like time can't stop thinking about
this is to stay on your mind when you're
going that type of [ __ ] you gotta get
over that [ __ ] but and then 84 I mean
that was like you weren't really doing
drugs and she looked at the end of the
hall please that was part of the [ __ ]
situation don't love again but I fell in
love you ever fall in love I did that
twice in my life I can't why your fall
in love with somebody but you know it
ain't gonna work but you still know yeah
this ain't good this is no yeah Dumbo I
got love my little one wouldn't have
left me like that no I want to god I'm
going to be a rapper in 84 the
heartbreak was so bad and get a piece of
[ __ ] for 16 months out damn you know
this - that want to have sex for 16
months
Irene offers good idea kind of kind of
creeped out my god like most people
think you get out of jail you just wanna
easily like get some [ __ ] and [ __ ]
back and I was like kind of like shell
shocks to you
it took me like Daniel a month before I
start [ __ ] oh I had 18 months and it
wasn't that I didn't want to see what's
out there yeah oh no ya gotta hear from
all you've been regrouping lately I'm
watching the evil regrouping he's going
back to the gym hard [ __ ] he's doing
open mic that's it he's regrouping he's
gonna start juicing again pretty soon no
that thing almost gave me diet because
they Dean dollar I got diabetes for my I
like the day I stopped diabetes like and
the day I stopped like my like my legs
were like its tingly and stuff so though
so now looking back you put so many
apples and grapes in until like too much
sugar to get the taste of the goddamn
Kayla
that apparently you can give yourself
diabetes so no disrespecting dealings
great now hook them eating like I won't
do right now I stopped smoking
cigarettes I gotta get some type of joy
and so I've been smashing [ __ ] I'll give
a [ __ ] [ __ ] it I'm try you cook no no
your wife cook no no see we got every
night damn you
oh Jesus Christ so bad breakfast - I
don't really eat breakfast like that but
I eat up we you did come in and you're
like 2 2 p.m. is a little early for a
meeting I'm like do have the early
against them at when you gotta ban you
it depends off cuz I'm saying I'm out
here I'm gonna party and plus you know
that time I don't know you might be
right but I don't know what I'm gonna
get into tonight
[ __ ] if I have a late night and 2 p.m.
to learn I may be still be I'm gonna get
up to noon I did that last night I could
her last night had a good time what time
Jang out so last night I can t remember
I just remember waking up and it was
only ten minutes of live the car like
[ __ ] so I had to rush and get up out of
there but got the job down
now I got a night to myself and we'll
figure it out sprite go coaster game do
we
imma stay a few more days I think I
don't know keeping it open oh music why
you here look musically thank you know
just showing you looking around
yeah thanks gonna get you good weather
it's like the same as the show it's all
little side I could warm my fur up those
white people crazy black man with a fur
with a white woman driving [ __ ]
crazy this [ __ ] - as soon as I saw you
sitting next to that chick there was a
chick at the counter there was no spaces
they all looked at you in that poor
chick just something crunched over like
all creeped up you didn't see that it
was [ __ ] crazy a black man with a
[Laughter]
yeah frankly is a dead [ __ ] me
it's a place that's what I bought that
go to go to UFC yeah B I remember that
[ __ ] is acceptable in Detroit yeah but
in Austin Texas you never get to wear it
Texas I think people in Texas would like
fur don't really don't isn't that good
I'm not saying it Texas one of those
faces amendable studies so hot out there
personally don't see [ __ ] like that
it's a Mensa multi-purpose just a little
bit blind with a fur [ __ ] jacket big
your pet fur coat in Texas [ __ ] that's
how I like it
easily I can put anything in here with
that I can just walk in this dog the as
I have a second Negro company of the
firaon and [ __ ] January that's
two years just add that's two years and
then bring it to the station where did
they gonna find that Mick found the
heroin the key the loop killed Castro
I'm gonna pin everything on you and
you're gonna be looking at 20 alive but
we're in a [ __ ] mink it is crazy
listen where I used to go on the road in
the mid-90s to the end of night is nice
to work Trevor ones and I used to go to
weird places did I tell you what I saw I
didn't see racism but I saw control
mm-hmm do you follow him saying yeah
like when I would go to places and I
know I mean he tries to be pretty much
segregated like that like you know but
no no it's a different type of control
it was like I would go like like some
play some boys it mm-hmm I do comedy and
after the comedy show the DJ comes on
everybody hangs up and it be in places
where there were you know 90% of the
population was [ __ ] white
yeah that I'm lying here because I got
coke that was amazing I noticed one
thing I noticed that there was black man
out that night single they kept that
black in check they were allowed to talk
to the white and this is like a rural
place these white chicks are dying the
second black thing over with that's so
it's a we're the Buffy are you a
Christian no way you got a dip into the
dark side he got me we'll get colored in
yeah that father's been tumbled for
twenty years don't hate black people
now they say good-looking and they look
at him they touch his skin just to make
sure no they've never seen a black man
before but they've heard of always
greater still [ __ ] boys he's wide
open I haven't been there in [ __ ] twenty
years but that was one town that was
very it was starting already
the boys he funny bone in 1995 was one
of the best clubs in the top ten clubs
in the country did check who booked it
knew the business and she got people to
go up there and the hotel they put gym
was a old [ __ ] hotel that was
Chinese Gothic Danny Brown it was like
from 1871 so everything would creep Oh
sir
everybody be cool the bars were cool you
know I went out a couple of nights but
how it's also famed in when I went there
mm-hmm and I'm like the third night I
had ass but all there was was mess
because at the time I bought it I mean
for seven nights and some [ __ ] knows
[ __ ] improvise move in live a little
and I was up the whole [ __ ] weekend
dawg
I was opening for Dave Titus mmm is that
his name uh Christine Boise Idaho
it had to be 1990 [ __ ] six mm-hmm and
I got a line the [ __ ] speed on a
Friday night it was considered speed I
went over to the bar I shared a picture
a beer with some waitresses and waiters
and they gave me the package there was
like 10 bucks
okay and I was in the bathroom I did two
[ __ ] blast dog you knew it would be
yeah nothing else going on what am I
gonna do I'm a [ __ ] junkie
there's 1990 saying I'm ready to go at
that book speed I'm on the road I'm
under I'm living on the [ __ ] moon I'm
waking up and whatever pop says yeah
whatever opens up so I got there in
those days commonly used to be Tuesday
through Sunday I think that Club was
Wednesday through Sunday some dog that's
five [ __ ] nights by Friday night I'm
scratching over so Friday night I got a
package at the bar
and did two bumps it burned the [ __ ] on
my nose like a feeling my walls and [ __ ]
and I went out in guys oh you know I
guess I was always like our Budweiser or
two and I gotta go I'm in [ __ ] gas I
went through two pinches of [ __ ] me
about myself
guys like I'm [ __ ] one at home well
they're the hello creepy and he got
creepy and then I said I gotta go mm-hmm
and I went back to the hotel room and
that cable and [ __ ] I Showtime and HBO
and at one point they had some dirty
[ __ ] out of the night jerked off it was
like fun next scene always 5:00 in the
[ __ ] morning good time LA and the
place is creeping the hotel room was
screamin and I had a little bit left and
I'm like you know what I'm coming down I
don't need that little bit I'm just
gonna savor for
tomorrow thanks see you at 7:00 in the
morning dog mixing I laid down and my
heart started pounding like it was gonna
fly out of my chest I had to get up and
leave the apartment
I started getting paranoid her at every
creak so I didn't sleep all Friday night
and then I wouldn't do boat shows Friday
Saturday and Saturday night and sleep oh
no I didn't fall asleep till Sunday
afternoon
like I wanna clock and I had to get up
at 6 to do the last show of the week
and I went back to the hotel and I just
went to sleep till next day like a
[ __ ] 12 the main uh knock on the door
that's how horrible two [ __ ] days I
was a lot of two books a two little
[ __ ] blast I must be jerked off
anything at that point god I could not
believe it
I could not cigarette then know how to
smoke 2006 no no no nothing then but
smoke weed I can't believe in the hotel
to smoke don't have a smoke and joint
after joint I don't know I didn't know
what was going on the weather was nice
you know there was like a little
alleyway or something behind the hotel
we could smoke or he was a comp except
you know the Boise there's a place by
the dumpster it was a horrible
experience because every time I thought
I was tired I would lay down and my
heart would start [ __ ] there's nothing
worth it man
and there's how to be like 96 but this
was seen I'm a you know me dog I'm
international I was locked up 88 on
Mondays this dude John Clark would bring
in his girlfriend were bringing in a
bubble in her mouth and it was minimum
security a speed in a balloon example
they wouldn't make out and then he had
it in his mouth
he wouldn't even swallow it he just take
it out during the visit or he leave it
in his mouth and since there was more
than security nobody ever really seen it
he take the visitations like me on off
days you took a job in the kitchen
mm-hmm and you took different days off
so I would
Mondays and Tuesdays for visits because
there's nobody else in a rumor you're
[ __ ]
well damn plus you could smuggle [ __ ]
nobody knows nothing
yeah it was little security guard thing
give a [ __ ]
sure why we Monday I would do speed
would that do it
yep doing it in 87 before they and it
was different in that your neighbors
that thing kept me up if I would do
speed why would you want to be up in
jail oh my god it was cuz I had a TV in
my room oh [ __ ]
you know I had books in my room I did
ask to the jail that's with the library
in one night we stayed up all [ __ ]
night and guards kept walking biased
there was like four of us the other the
other in vics didn't know that means the
librarian had done the ass mm-hmm and
the guard kept passing by which they
probably wrote us up my report usually
they piss you mmm when guards see that
type of activity the next day you get a
year in the house then they can't trace
hassling oh really
nothing those days they couldn't and all
the in big snow it acident you know
that's like a movie because they
couldn't test you faster probably had a
son in prison seen everybody it was
happy where when you take an essence in
yourself as it freaks me out man I'll
get free talents to folks on my asses
hell no up up see it colors up the look
so I told you giggles and colors right
now leave all right man I'm doing just
the same as you damming up tight I'm
kicking it man meat is delicious
business ain't too crazy hot time I did
some mushrooms I [ __ ] lord of the
rains came on him one photos came up a
TVI 3000 cleveland i was running up the
streets with my socks they started
raining I thought I was in Tokyo and
there's a long wet again Cleveland's not
like a litter place down
but but some reason SC I thought I was
in Japan would you bow your eyes dial
into some [ __ ] holy so you're getting
more light now Vegas I've trip like I'm
done baller Vegas eatin like edibles the
first couple times and walking to the
casino at 2:00 in the morning
mm-hmm its meaning back mm-hm there's
still a couple tables it's got a [ __ ]
wind with yeah I buy I didn't walk into
Las Vegas I used to have it no every boy
in Vegas he's in trouble
i sweating out I had a guy in Vegas that
oh yeah do is calm I just wanna go bring
you could be it whatever hotel you you
just call this number
wait yet hangs me I'm here or room yeah
and you know during you were a comic so
they would give you a pretty good room
never afraid of you and haven't been
like you can get up without the card hmm
and he tight twenty minutes
there's also next thing you know yet the
door he knew everybody says I can tell
he was paying everybody he coming to
your hotel room what do you want he
would give you an eight ball they give
you a calm down package what the [ __ ]
I don't Venice ensues annexes and
percocets and to [ __ ] in left I guess
yeah nobody does anymore my god I would
eat everything
no just eat the whole come down without
me the coke for an hour I would [ __ ]
go right to bed
oh my god yeah yeah that [ __ ] DVD store
and who like I I know for a fact he's so
Christmas card no no but it's crazy
because even four years you know I mean
I haven't done coke ten years but I
would say I found out who and what he
really did I was introduced to him at
The Comedy Store in a really weird way
and he gave me a card and then my buddy
who I was copping from that introduced
me told told me if you ever in Vegas any
son call that car alright cool
at that time I wasn't going to Vegas and
all of a sudden I started getting work
in Vegas with Rogan and I would go to
Vegas with him and call him the lame
before any time and caught call me when
you land
mm-hmm it was that easy there I'll and
me Rogan and Adi and Duncan are we go
eat we don't go back to our rooms before
the weigh-in I would call him and within
[ __ ] 20 minutes I have a package in
my room when I come down back it's Dan I
already had the night set easy call I'd
hide the coke I'd do the show at Joe
Rogan mm-hmm and when he will not stay
peeled and you could call that good
numbers many times as you want
damn ain't nobody gonna answer Vegas is
crazy bit every time I'm in Vegas I
never leave my hotel really I do we get
super late and I just came Dean I can't
sleep so I like pop it when i gamble to
lose me I never again would continue are
you talking about you gamble at this
gamble to lose I mean I don't play we're
intense don't win it so I just be
betting crazy doing dumb [ __ ] and I win
something
I win I reckon gamble put your game of
choice I play I play craps of course but
I one time my favorite actually is just
war I was in don't encourage them please
lose your entire life is a been damn
great oh my god Danny
all right know what happened I got up I
was up like I started yeah you could get
low you win ten up quickest [ __ ] me
laughs and then I just bet I bet it all
on what are you talking about gambling -
yeah
that was a gamble was it you will
neither Venus I wasn't me and then yeah
the kid in Denver that we were talking
about Las Vegas the comedian real cool
guy the second night he was talking
about he was a gambler
oh yeah bran Tobler yes he was talking
about that he was a gambler dude in
Vegas and how they they lose it's
correct it's a truth ain't no benefit as
addictive men you know I've seen Detroit
change from them putting the casinos in
their life you know all those old people
they used to work at like the factory
jobs and Chrysler and [ __ ] like that and
they pretty much they spent all the
retirement money at the casino
so now [ __ ] is [ __ ] up now
yeah whenever like the people the old
ladies who play the slot that [ __ ] up
the city like all Deeb's all the people
who have money man no casinos man you
seen it like that's why our
neighborhoods just looking the way they
looking let the traitors on come up is
changing and it's scary when you go to
Vegas and they have like the line for
people who are doing their check-cashing
mm-hmm at the casino my god come on
don't do it there oh man that was
another crazy addiction I went to for
about four months
gambling that took of sports but oh yeah
I took a beating at the age of 19 mmm
I ended up okay even I'm running away I
may be old a grandson but my body got
into a deep hole and I tell you guys I
didn't like paying the [ __ ] bookie it
bothered me to pay a [ __ ]
Thursday's especially when you have to
work for money when you need a job yeah
you're gonna pay somebody on a Thursday
because you want to bet [ __ ] some
stupid [ __ ] thing mmm and that's why I
stopped doesn't let's get paid man but
you know what the odds always against
you I never was one to lose I swear I
would love gambling we do shoot dice in
the bathroom at school and I just always
lost so I gambling was never my thing
ended I somehow got to my extremely
suburban high school yeah
I don't know how I got there but we've
just started playing craps yeah you know
it was I I think was just dying
something just hiring them okay no no I
used to come up on side betting but
never just me on the dices or rat yeah I
was I was really telling my mommy that
made 725 an hour I was like I'm on mmm
I did a couple times you know it's so
easy to really like I just read this
book the corporation when that's coming
out in the 20th and it was basically
revolved around sports paper but it was
revolved around numbers betting and how
this guy made this business just just
you know he was making enormous brother
profits and it doesn't like he they
described bookmakers that were
knowledgeable that could be up one day
hundreds of thousands and the next day
that got cocky and it dumped off enough
and they got something all you need is
one guy and coming in place $50 $50
number that's 25,000 and people do it
all the time no no my mom would pop a
number 50 bucks 50 bucks every day [ __ ]
that was a are you crazy my mom would
put 50 on 604 517 and 516 every [ __ ]
day of the week
that was just for one numbers guy that's
my god that's crazy
[ __ ] no bro that's like I said me and my
buddies and it's weird because my the
family I lived with after the benders -
Ronnie's mr. Ronnie God rest his soul
[ __ ] straight-up [ __ ] gentleman
great guy he was the head of this place
where I had dad like knitting stuff and
he used to tell us this and guys if you
wanna gamble for entertainment that
five-time that's what he would do mm-hm
and you go once you start going on that
you guys are gonna lose
yeah and we'll like [ __ ] you cuz
everybody trying to get review window
you know what though you don't know what
you're doing and he would tell me look I
bet one game I made 25 bucks let him get
off the couch exactly when I go to the
ball I pick up the 25 bucks and I drink
for free all [ __ ] day mm-hm
he had a great logic nullus we thought
we knew more than that hmm and all he
included his son me my friend ferny my
friend stinky we all got into [ __ ] it
huge holes the [ __ ] I had to do to bail
out a hole one thought well we bet off
and when we were 18
we better Monday Night Football for
2,500 bucks just like me putting the
better with you day [ __ ] like oh you
want Thursday yeah and tell you I don't
have your money
haha I'm your friend bro you're gonna
put you know put me in this position
so dude I put the bed it was a high
school teacher night mm-hmm
that was a good dude how'd you make it
sport so we ended up robbing a [ __ ]
jewelry store to pay the lot of [ __ ]
money
yeah man because you know it was just
kid [ __ ] [ __ ] crazy betting Monday
night I got clobbered you have no idea
the beatings I took sports betting when
I was in high school and people in you
gotta be crazy that's an addiction then
wait till basketball comes up mmm what
basketball comes out that's every day
that's how I get you to take a chair
every day next thing you know you've
been in basketball and you're betting
basketball Paul ways to catch up and
then you're losing that that's you give
hockey try okay I bet sports you don't
even know about sometimes you call a
friend ears let me ask you a question
your are yeah
yeah you know in fact I'm watch my game
right that you kind of interrupting it
Joey was like you had a bet between this
team and this team who would you bet me
go well I like this team and this team
of defense of this and sometimes I get
lucky sometimes I'd win with but for the
most part I just kept taking a beating
guys yeah and some bookies I paid back
so my paid half they never bothered me
again you know mm-hmm it was just stupid
thing else to penny I was in a couple
times I bet yeah more than a couple of
times
I bet way over my head and I would just
get the trouble with people to disappear
for a while oh [ __ ]
all right enough Vanessa see you soon
see you soon love you know we never had
that Michigan I don't think I'm gonna
get sprayed like back in the day but no
knows nothing about cars
yeah I don't know but I played dice - I
don't know member if I won of that I'm
gonna learn about that [ __ ] like I just
I just know that I'm not good at it yeah
that's how I just I'd do it higher up
your health I appreciate it mm-hmm I see
we should go on belay for me sometimes I
get lucky when I'm in Vegas I still put
a better from time to time don't get me
wrong but it's not that crazy the cellar
and I know $50 ain't gonna make me a
break me and I'm there anyway to watch
the you I've seen exactly I might as
well put about it yes I have you ever
won anything on those video poker games
yeah a couple times this last time I
went I hit four three four loves old
[ __ ] you kidding is still down mm-hmm
just thought the video roulette one I
hit on one of them one time is like fine
yeah so well you could go and have a
great time in Vegas I like doing night
by myself when you're stoned yeah and
you can't sleep anyway it's better to
sing the room watch TV you got a Spanish
they just plain just try you look like
that's it 50 bucks no me candy a big I
don't go to the ATM's at the casinos
that's all I have oh yeah you know you
I'll be [ __ ] up did you get that book
I get that one thing I haven't gone up a
couple times gonna say when you lose
like [ __ ] that
I've lost my phone I gotta get back and
then you are it's over with once you
start thinking like that you already
lost
well I can't I get them porno 1,400 I
mean I guess I think I'm kind of I think
I'm watching enough basketball where I
think I'd be good with betting and
betting on basketball but I feel like I
just like kisses every time I bet on
something they always lose listen bro
here's the back bet it's so funny when I
work for a squad betting service we
would have a meeting every day
mm-hmm and you know you have to lie on
the phone you have to tell people you
doing 70 percent remember what the kid
was saying what's the best people could
do like 60 or 50 50 and people would say
nobody could do that you know and
everybody will always say he was a smart
guy that got a Tranio because I admire
him a lot and a lot of this [ __ ] I do
today is because of him
and he used to go listen it's plain and
simple mmm-hmm you guys type up arts
lead stir you know he goes arts leads
Pete Rose
[Music]
[ __ ] all these guys got busted hmm
they played the game yeah they still
lost Michael joy youtuber do you really
YouTube you read them but what's the
first name I Center our art suite sir
oh no that's Google carts leads to
whatever that is Yahoo Google
football players will gamble you're
gonna take a piece of my friend Medicaid
well their quarterback Alex Fisher yeah
compulsive gambler reader knows a
four-decade compulsive gambler habit
really ending a teen years I kept you at
my glass Julie reader for my uncle Joey
I can't see how I don't see
[Music]
I gave him 10 years committed 20
felonies
gambled away much of his salary
somebody stole 1.5 mil thick dough this
guy went crazy though he was a
quarterback yeah and if you look there
was a couple of them you know Petros
allegedly gambled so if these guys were
involved in the sport and they couldn't
[ __ ] win they couldn't you it's like
and I haven't threw my dream to be able
to go to the tables with that amount of
money but then everyone you talk to who
has that stack is like I'm down 5,000
like damn man yeah 5,000 mm-hmm that's
what you gotta do I guess going once
he stole five hundred thousand from a
dozen individuals including his own
father what the [ __ ] this is a booby
bear just ours this guy was the first
kid yes got out 2006 I don't want a half
a million dollars in restitution that's
it
yeah all right I maybe just did did man
years ago get the [ __ ] out of here poor
sweets I didn't know is that bad no you
still like it just got a 2007
he's in prison gonna be back in there
again please date 2020 and he got
Parkinson's God Daniel
oh yeah used to kiss a duck this guy's
gonna win this guy Lee it was hard a
wire fraud bank fraud yeah no they went
crazy
I'm timid this was in 2011 though that's
crazy
still out here though after he defended
another team oh my god
he's got out 14 you did it back I did
the same [ __ ]
some people addicted to jail that's what
this shows me this guy was this all
started with [ __ ] gambling football
he got suspended did he say that he got
suspended
yeah I was me or thrown out of the
league and I don't remember what what
happened he was arrested in 87 for a
multi-million dollar sports betting
operation you pled guilty to illegal
gambling in April and the Commissioner
didn't let him sign on the team
was he banned for life uh no I think he
played again no he said it's after that
that I'm parts of three seasons he
played only 13 games yeah thinking maybe
yeah primarily back up her mom pop roles
he signed briefly in the Canadian League
and then the Arena League this poor
bastard you know he played arena I saw
my mom in my mom was a [ __ ] gambling
junkie and nothing was horses and
baseball dog mm-hmm and I think back now
you know like bookies would koala on the
regular what's going on what do you want
to do tonight
hmm and she loved chasing it there's
people who really love chasing it that
way for me it's a scary [ __ ] idea yeah
it's a [ __ ] terrible [ __ ] way you
know why just go play the lotto you
gonna drop a dollar anyway nobody gets
their feelings hurt I'm like you go no
no we know no success stories out of
this though mmm I like you don't listen
if I was good at it I love going to
Vegas and betting on a fight with it
yeah I love I look at another car that's
different I love it I like boxing baby
don't you too bright man I go the first
thing I do when I check in with I'm
working with Joe but when I'm checking
on the way and I come down and I go to
the board I look at the line mm-hmm and
I don't even look at the two main fight
mm-hmm I look at the undercard
thanks for the money is it's gambling it
doesn't matter what you bet you want to
sit there being Johnny swarming or you
want to win money it's that simple
I've always been an underdog yeah and
then they start [ __ ] with you they
get you with the [ __ ] side bets yeah
that's what that's gonna get you listen
just do like a [ __ ] game bat it with
everything you believe in it and watch
the results that's all you can do worst
case scenario you bet ten times
you go six and four mm-hmm you make two
thousand [ __ ] dollars but you have to
do a walk ten weeks in a row and stick
to it
and I guarantee you make money one
[ __ ] game blasted for 2500 you see
the line you see the weather something
that you see and I guarantee you'll
[ __ ] win money what we know I do have
a strategy and I know it was a pacer
game a few years ago but I get when you
see a mistake that they make because I
don't want to make mistakes that I'll
make a recipe should be tripping dough
so yeah that's true what they NBA reps
they be it's going crazy right now man
very game they [ __ ] up yeah but you
gotta remember one [ __ ] thing dog
it's it's [ __ ] tough but you can't
blame it on the reps
you can't blame every [ __ ] thing on
the goddamn MBA so I don't even know
what's going on LeBron and then there's
a college scandal now oh yeah that's
[ __ ] you know just [ __ ] it up this
has been going on people for [ __ ] we
went over this before leader we've had
about fifty [ __ ] thousand years
mm-hmm that's anyway that's a complete
difference but you gotta get deep these
kids are poor mm-hmm fact you're going
into the [ __ ] together people that
you know you want to recruit mm-hmm you
got gonna slows you gotta go to this law
officer yeah you want a kid that has
never left his [ __ ] neighborhood to
pick up and go to your school play
football maybe he wants his auntie
winner
whoever you wanted mama with mm-hmm
maybe his mom is doing time he was
raised by his grandmother he wants his
grandmother well maybe that's the
deciding factor for him to go to that
college that costs money man affects
$100,000 payoff stay with doing scamming
one of the shoe companies nobody have to
start letting him go to the NBA or the
high school again there's longer things
will happen
are they going overseas no I'm not mom :
other than not Muslim but they can I
mean yeah yes sir you can't go into the
MV ain't no more from high school one
year you got do one here so everything
everybody doing one in dinners anyway
most high recruits just going going to
college you know you only get in that
prayer for one year so that [ __ ] up it
[ __ ] up college to to be honest but now
do we know anything [ __ ] I
believe [ __ ] crazy I mean they need to
pay him though to be honest they need to
set up some type of payment situation
for college athletes man that's the only
way it's gonna work
there's so much money in college yeah
because he's selling new jerseys they've
been video parents there you know when I
was when I was doing all that stupid
[ __ ] in 87 I I left [ __ ] Aspen
overnight and doing I was so paranoid
that night when I left a husband mm-hmm
it was the night after Thanksgiving 1986
mm-hmm I left one ounce of the prettiest
cocaine oh [ __ ] you ever saw in your
life in the height of my cocaine
addiction I showed up with a pound for
gay z-weed there and I already owed this
chick like [ __ ] 15 grand I think I've
done me a big favor
I know I owe you money I've know you're
at this story before but I got a client
that needs this I think it was a half
ounce mm-hmm and I go I'll leave this
cup out we this collateral this weed
looked great but it was a Fugazi
somebody sold it to me and scanned me
I'm saying [ __ ] from those mushrooms I
just saw the screen turn on me like I
was at the doctor's office I'm saying it
again we told us a few creepy things
gonna just be a Kudo
you guys ain't know what the [ __ ] we're
talking the mushrooms man no no no we're
talking about summer full of mushrooms I
was on your story about oh he's an aspen
it was I'm a sir
that's what the prettiest cocaine oh
yeah easily Lisa I had a couple grand in
my pocket that I owe it to people like I
told people give me money cuz I'll come
back in an hour call him hell I'm gonna
do it don't worry it all figured out I
scam like four [ __ ] people fight two
grand
yeah we drove like three hours overnight
and I could stop snorts all weekend we
had a good hotel
mmm-hmm so we know we check into a hotel
through two lines ago and we checked out
driver though yeah we thought the cops
are chasing us every hotel we went there
knowing my god it was terrible
- terrible - that's a - nothing worse
than knowing somebody man at their whole
situation of just oh man it's scary it's
scary that scares a slippery slope yeah
it's best to drugs like we didn't drugs
and Bob and money and [ __ ] man I feel so
bad for my ex-wife that poor girl mm-hmm
she was [ __ ] up that night I heard of
driving and I was paranoid his [ __ ]
that car hmm Christ I was seeing so long
[Music]
we went to her wheel and and Boulder my
parents didn't know that we were
together they knew
but they know we lived together saw the
first night we showed up at her sister's
house wish she lived on the hill in
Baldwin mm-hmm and Mitch let us sleep on
the floor in the basement we were and I
have like one 8-ball left
oh [ __ ] in the middle um that I started
snore then look at me going what the
[ __ ] you don't you know I'm doing take
your panties off him my mom now is guys
I was gone that was 20-some years old I
was gone like we stayed there for a
while and that thing I like a little a
weekly apartment mm-hmm and that roach
is a [ __ ] well my roommates they were
coked up as I was oh well I'm getting to
we're talking about boosters I worked I
got a job right away as a car wiper and
at the boulder puddle local car wash in
Boulder great place great people he
owners a great people him in his wife
they were boosters bro they went to
every game they flew the hairy ball game
they went to all the dinners I forget
how much they donated out of that place
that money was a that place is a car
wreck uh-huh a cash register especially
in the winter because of the salt mm-hmm
and the ice oh my god have to add after
it snowed and the Sun will come up
there'd be a line from here all the way
down the [ __ ] Magnolia I'm not
kidding you'd be wiping cars all [ __ ]
day I love the tips the car wash
business in those days guys crazy
I see the car wash business we got what
three car washes around it you get it
it takes a half hour they doing nothing
mm-hmm there will also how we were
professionals at the park I started as a
car wipe it down Carl I poured out and
then I got promoted to a guy that drives
the car out was that that so when the
car comes out of the tunnel oh yeah
it stops I gotta get it and slam the
door put it in gear and drive it to
whatever station is open [ __ ] for the
guys that drugged me I thought I was all
cool as [ __ ] then took me about a month
in november/december a wiping down cause
I showed up on time every more than
fifteen minutes before that but I was
also Robin okay sometimes people give
you three bugs you only put two in a
basket no you put one in the basket keep
two with the receipt so I was also when
I was a card I learned how to steal when
I was a [ __ ] a wiper mm-hmm and then
when I was a [ __ ] car driver listen
you take ten cars you take 50 cents from
each car that's four bucks yes I have 5
bucks 5 bucks 5 bucks good that two
[ __ ] heroes middle boy so between
that is stealing tips plus you know 750
an hour so I was the attic got in the
car and drove it on a better job at cars
huh no no I think wipers better get more
tips it gets better
oh yeah I quit not one day I was walking
by because I moved down the corner
mm-hmm well I got married and the guy
beeped at me and he called me only just
what's up how you doing
we started talking his name was rich I
stole all this got my life I think about
of my life was a good solid white doing
bald and he goes you looking for a job
and he goes I'm looking for a host a
Salesman and you pull up you gotta sell
them products
everything like what hack it is like I
can just oh okay
be being a [ __ ] house again
what you want you look right good like a
[ __ ] what are you gonna get the
dog - I'm gonna get the usual look
what's a special you know saying there
was always a special so the special I
would rope you with you was a special is
this already clearly at 95 I throw on
the registry but do me a favor let me
get you four tools for the wax because
the wax was ten dollars I wouldn't below
the ticket
dog I had a fan and the girl inside came
to me one day I was selling outside now
a scam a little bit but they must but
there was a mushroom just mm-hm
the scam was when the girl from the
register inside came to me and she goes
will make out a lot of money you're
making them a lot of money you're a good
sound what if you did it this way and
I'll split the money with their dog that
bitch's give me a ton of money every
time I work because I thought I was a
coke fiend one of my thinking and I
would work three days a week I was
making two grand the way she sang we
were stealing two grand a week like we
were splitting four grand a week on the
car WA and dog it was one month two
months three months it was month and a
month that to me would come on then they
would ask him I tell paying cash that
but see on that so she would know when
she'd ring him up that she didn't have
to ring him up yeah it was crazy it was
serious stealing all the cast ones the
whole [ __ ] I just and every [ __ ]
day damn about me this chick was robbing
a blade she would come up to me
throughout the day and just give me two
hundred 150 and then I would leave there
with [ __ ] seven on your side of cash
I was living like a doctor and nobody
knew it and I can't be doing a month
after month after month after month and
about the eighth month I started getting
bad
I'm like this Lee's people were stupid
but they investor mm-hmm some reason I
figure out this fan and it was dog the
last I gave my notice in that Louis last
two weeks I robbed with six hands we
started figuring out how to rob the
credit cards then oh my god we would get
them for a thousand fifteen on your day
she was sad when I quit she's like Joey
you don't understand you cannot quit I'm
making too much money I've just bought a
new car
she went over a [ __ ] head this is
chick was 21 but the reason she was
younger than I was the reason why I was
doing it when I was she had cover she
was somebody in the police department
uncle my dad was a sheriff or something
something we always had an out she
always said she had an out so I was one
day I was like you know well I ain't
stupid
I've been to prison already you know he
was gonna pay up steal you year's new
dog I knew it they were gonna figure it
out if they figured it out I was on
probation you know how he's gonna write
innovation because I worked there in the
DEA and I became friendly with the D I
didn't know he was a DEA hmm I just used
to talk about a guy then I wouldn't ask
him what he did so I told him what I
didn't it oh my god I remember that case
oh sorry when I started talking I one
day I went damn Elena listen I want to
move back to New York but I can't
because of the probation and he goes
have your attorney draft something a
sentence for me his name was wise bill
why something I'm taking out fire after
the job an eighth day but
[Music]
that guy got me on probation at that car
wash
plus I got to see all the undercover
cops okay that was really a judge oh
that wasn't they have their cars washed
publicly yeah that's we had an account
with the police department okay so they
would come in and say the boulder county
sheriff's office of Boulder County
Police old the County Sheriff's Office
for kind of weird because if you're a
bollock county sheriff's office you work
a different place mm-hmm so people don't
recognize you're originally from Denver
Boulder or how the [ __ ] are you an
undercover cop mm-hmm so what does doo
doo doo would be like go to Fort Collins
but I would also see the guys that would
come in to work from other jurisdictions
that would get that car wash out of me
own so I got to learn how they were
starting to bust people and then finally
after six months there was one the cover
cop that was cool mm-hmm and he knew
what I had done and he knew that I know
we started talking and we start talking
about criminals that I had been doing
time with that he busted then and it was
dog you know it was a just a I learned a
lot at that [ __ ] place I learned how
to sell there that was my first real
experience with upselling people and
bumping him up like I'm making you pay
more for what the special is I'm
tricking you mm-hmm it was the [ __ ]
way and everything was air white they
told you this thing only cost $2 this
stuff costs 10 cents yeah even if it
says 69 cents if you drop it 10 cents
you still we're still making a property
any other percentage I don't I made
money there Oh the pay plant at the end
of the week like at the end the weekend
you you had a commission I would pull
$17 an hour
that was a lot of [ __ ] money in 1990
guys this is a year or two before calmly
I was pulled not a little scam I was the
halfway house dog if I would've got
caught stealing from them about halfway
house that would have cleaned me up for
years and for years I quit but the point
of the story is they would be big big
time boosters mm-hmm like they gave half
their [ __ ] salary in that car wash to
the University of Colorado and they got
like 50 yard tickets and they got the
special blankets and they also gave jobs
to the University of Colorado football
players yeah one of my first friends you
know a movie I went to see when you eat
you won't even born with me and him that
he was like a tackle and he was wiping
causing the hail a lot of black football
players yeah that's one thing I game
they got well I guarantee those
[ __ ] on me a lot more than I
was made
mm-hmm you know I believe the devil
football players I mean that kid double
dated one night and with the see golden
job go to the child Eddie Murphy Murphy
I born in 81 I think yeah that was 88
yeah Brady won't you ever see a movie
yeah I don't think so
Oh teletype goldens house a little tiny
world yeah I remember that that was
tight
what a crazy [ __ ] world my friend now
I know why your rep I guess for shout
outs he'll quickly get the party started
ashes have more questions everybody a
little bit Dylan James Frey I love you
Ryan Seagal Daryl Wade West Tom gavest
now's his daughter and his daughter Don
Tom Gaines and your beautiful daughter
give her a shout I know she's nine years
old set three Spain David
Kevin Dome and Christians baby you know
I love your mother [ __ ] don't forget
March 10th working out with uncle Joey
at the ice house 15 bucks on the
Saturday 7:30 show you'll have it back
in the appointment by 10:30 mm-hmm doing
the dirty and then March 21st on a
Wednesday night the first show sold out
so they added a second at 10:30 [ __ ]
work on the 22nd [ __ ] it
start on st. Paddy's Day and keep going
to the 22nd that's right
what's going on with you play you
performing you did a festival I got
Chicago coming up on March 12 15 and
then I go to Iceland March 16 my
birthday and daenam and Alaska and April
but for the most part pretty chill I'm
working on his album so I can't really I
got it and this Muse I mix music you
know you have a label your own label no
I'm signed to work records which is
pretty much your own uk-based label
independent label from Bryant email
no I'm saying so it's cool I like it
over there I didn't go to London a lot
you know so that's the good part about
it and I was always a fan of that label
too because they just put out a lot of
like experimental and cool stuff he's
not really too many rappers on a label
so it was kind of like you know it's
cool it's cool place I can't believe
like God you know you never really
listened till the Eagles are you all up
on the girls cool [ __ ] door as well
that's what that was
one of these nights was one of the first
real rock songs I was like wait a sec
mm-hmm I'm feeling this [ __ ] cuz I
refused to listen to rock music mm-hmm
like I didn't like the long hair this is
what I was a karate dude and Bruce Lee
was dead that was still a little pissed
off Bruce Lee died when I was 10 I was
pissed
leather than half 12 is [ __ ] I
discovered women trying to discover that
little chick
Bruce Lee was my life or from Bruce Lee
that little dry and open them yeah
that's crazy [ __ ]
uh no time somebody Eagles the Eagles so
I was in Miami song came up I was a kid
in Miami and I went nuts I went home and
bought the [ __ ] out that one of these
nights the first one and then I bought
Hotel California and that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] just straight-up brilliant yeah
and I couldn't wait to get home from
school at 3:00 cuz nobody was home till
5:00 hmm and I would go upstairs and
play the living room and I would hang
guitar the whole California no kid in
town [ __ ]
I love the [ __ ] you know I'm gonna check
it out I'm definitely take it on then
the one with the end and the Indian came
in the bass player the big Indian and
they did the long run and that's a good
album tow dog that's a badass sound you
know the brothers Johnson I know put on
brothers Johnson
let me see I thought you little my
brothers Jonathan brothers John oh
brother I want to see you two brothers
Johnson
well these guys are called this had to
be 75 okay
these guys with two brothers two family
I'm not saying african-american I'm
saying they were really brother well
brothers brothers John's brother yes dad
a couple big hits there we go all right
I'll be gosh strawberry leather number
23 you don't know this [ __ ]
maybe yeah you do you know this [ __ ] dog
right there that was there were two
brothers that were funky to take the
play they were guitar and they could
play the bass they will call okay and
then go to that next one right there
I'll be good to you right then one with
the blue on the top no tomorrow Lee
yeah renders ok this is my jam when I
was a kid you know they used to come to
the comedy straw when I first we got
there they were friends with Chewie well
I saw that the comedy store
I nearly [ __ ] died to do with the big
natural but this is one of the biggest
SARS this is thousand love with New
Yorker
that was Helene yes I miss my old school
his mouth
she mop up grandma Oh share we go
[Music]
what's ugly going going we're going deep
[ __ ] the murky waters we're done with
this [ __ ] Oh all right click on to my
boy right there the third video all the
way down with just out of respect
yeah result just out of respect for my
favorite bit don't ask no questions
this is one black people black people
this is my life this is it when you have
the best talking part if anybody knows
how his youth Jones you get them on the
podcast please contact me immediately
Debbie alleges this guy is one of my
all-time favorites
[Music]
what
[Music]
have a bit of a Oh speed lovely speed it
up to the middle right there yeah I got
him clapping for speed right yeah Dennis
Lee oh [ __ ]
his cousin shut up this is one of my
all-time favorite gender
[Music]
he's committed do you think there was an
acting school this guy is still waiting
for a dirt road let's the father to my
first impulse was to run up on you go
Rams give out the jammy a flat glass
bowl see this $3,700 links we're going
to say try the top four you try to copy
the banks check out every time every day
can't stall his credit card was a little
original play
let's count every piece of jewelry I
have abortion good back to the slow in a
closet you ain't got nothing everything
came here with is packed everybody gets
right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] the world up you close the package
remember this right here leave this on
you Lube oh yeah mm-hmm
oh I know club new boat you remember
this this is all school right here for
you to there's another go on for you
take oh [ __ ] what oh [ __ ]
[Music]
this is all school good this is about
the time I went to prison right here
this is straight-up cocaine you
[Music]
[Music]
old-school shifty right listen we're
just trying to [ __ ] drop some
knowledge on you and that Thursday
[ __ ] more than what else you gonna do
with your life exactly my man Dee Brown
is in the house a sub down something's
going [ __ ] down this weekend I know
we're gonna be I'm not doing nothing uh
I got a play date on Saturday mm-hmm
you know keep it light I got swimming
tomorrow with her 4:30
I got a drop her off my [ __ ] glasses
tomorrow as well as I sign his kind of
young people cherish your [ __ ]
eyesight cherish it and you know what
man the funk between the computer and
then and get north to blow that was the
demolition of my eyesight I had great
eyesight all my [ __ ] life and about
45 started I started writing on the
computer and immediately immediately dog
my eyesight went somewhere but it was ok
it was manageable
mm-hmm I stayed on top but I got the
glasses I got the reading glasses god
forbid you lose your reading glasses oh
man it's like dropping that gram of coke
at the restaurant were your last son
alone you [ __ ] panic I kept breaking
my glasses was a [ __ ] nightmare and
then I started taking people's advice
just go to Cosmo by the 10 [ __ ]
eyeglass-cam
so you can have I mean you need them
everywhere yeah and then bro it gets to
the point where you can't even read
checks then I don't have a restaurant
like even with the glasses on and that's
to the point on that damn I catch myself
watching TV or my left eye hmm that
means my right eye is gone or something
you know
and so I gotta really have fun and I've
been doing worse for us like we staring
at phones and computers oh yeah I need
glasses I know you think it accelerates
to flesh it right [ __ ] us up yeah
because we hold it right next time I
have my [ __ ] I don't see as well do
you know I could see I'll be 37 and you
feel it already yeah I didn't feel it
twice I knows the cocktail is different
man like I used to I could see way back
I was messing you know how long I've had
I've had a computer since yes forever
she's my old school probably I think
because I was always a reader you got I
gotta tell you guys I was always a read
I got trained in the seventh grade when
I got left back the [ __ ] dude made
you read one book every month and he
gave me an oral [ __ ] exam he wouldn't
make it do a book report yeah yeah look
and I loved it till today I still just
read this [ __ ] book in three days
this corporation yeah I love it but I
don't know what happened I started
writing early in the morning and that's
what I noticed it I'm good buddy here on
the computer mm-hmm I know with age of
deteriorates well it went quick at that
point
damn at that point and we're from like
[ __ ] ten to seven and I was like wow
this is noticeable right now I'm in like
three-and-a-half like I have to squint I
have to get the [ __ ] I thought you
and get the light out
even with glasses I don't even know what
I'm up to
you know it's buy things at CVS and you
buy these and you lose these mm-hmm and
I'm up to like [ __ ] 2.75 a 3.0 I
don't [ __ ] know now so I really went
to the eye doctor there I basically got
I get that 10 to 10
then take number [ __ ] three and send
online mm-hmm they pick mine up really
get my glasses and I'm gonna forget the
[ __ ] out and maybe train tomorrow yeah
what do you got going out my friend
won't just kick it I don't know pride
see a couple friends you know
see Charlie - oh no I'm just playing it
by here for right now I thought it was
gonna be nice out here man but [ __ ] I
guess I don't know just looking walk
before you dropped your record label I
mean we use were you are struggling at
all in the beginning ever oh yeah it
took me forever I think I didn't um I
didn't put out my first project on a
label till I was 30 so my whole 20 is I
was trying to be a rapper so are you
sure yeah my first help me come up till
I was 30 really I mean I had mixed tapes
before it in but I will go like I said
I'll go to New York take a great Hanoi
York on a weekend you know how would you
make a living as a rapper I was I was
selling dope dude selling weed so you
were so we'd mm-hmm that's pretty much
how I put out my first like my first
project that I get myself hot soup I get
out of weed money pretty much just paid
most of your time bought beats you know
and just put it on bunch of beach I mean
now
back then it was it was I got just one
working with one producer so I just you
know cash them out like that so well I
got buying beat by beat you know but
beats man it's a slippery slope now
that's a slippery slope they could go
you can I mean I don't know the slippery
slope you play a piano now play I played
trumpet a little bit now that element
yet only instrument I play but I've just
recently started taking guitar lessons
just to have something to do with my
time man it's number having least
something to make me you know have more
musical now makes you think no different
and it's hard as [ __ ] I guess cuz I've
got small hands so but anything cool is
this something good get out the house
you know so I've been doing that
for the most part yeah I'm just really
gonna finish this album so the next few
months I'm really just got a lock all
the way in and knock it out look I'm
cyst
I've got a good I know what I want to do
now that's the thing you know I think
that's the hardest part for me is just
figuring out what I want to do what I
wanted to sound like and I'm and I'm
pretty much got that so now it's all
about executing so I'm at that point not
so we figure it out we'll figure it out
but hopefully I hope to have it out [ __ ]
before this year over it you know takes
time yeah I mean is that this work on it
every day that's all I could do
especially you process got a trace right
process it's like right now I'm waiting
on Netflix there's nothing I can do
mm-hmm I could just keep going out I
could sharpen the material so when
Netflix calls I cut it down the fat yeah
it's a 30-minute [ __ ] special I'm
gonna do right now oh god yeah thank you
my boy leaves a good [ __ ] right yeah
he's gonna do well in this that's right
I'm trying that's right Lee oh yeah for
the most part I just want to know like I
said got the movie coming out and around
that time too so we'll see how that
works Oh - what is the movies that come
out August so that should be tight so
I'm wannabes you coming back for the
premiere the whole thing I don't know
I depend [ __ ] they invite you back yeah
the invite me I'll come but for the most
part [ __ ] I hope you I'll be on the road
but in I won't least put the album out
around that time or maybe a little bit
after I don't know but hopefully most
likely with me always put out more like
October November every two years so it
should be coming this would be good
or you look good you're healthy and then
I tore that [ __ ] for three years
festivals not really the festival will
start in the summer right like moving
maize in the summer that's when you get
locked into but man but I just you know
see with me I put out my I'm long put
out my oven mmm looks I almost almost
been two years so I got her even put
another one out to get back cuz I played
all the festivals last year with my you
know every time I put it Albemarle I
play him in there
just I got a chill you can't you know
I'm saying but for the most part I
played like I'm going us Slovakia and
[ __ ] like that
yeah so I was a little [ __ ] block you
is that would have call it it's amazing
like these other countries that like
kids in Cuba they have a heavy metal
scene mm-hmm like this hidden heavy
metal little rap everywhere man they
don't love rap everywhere you know it's
it's a universal [ __ ] music is so
[ __ ] universal it's crazy but yeah I
love like Europe I've had a bigger fan
base in Europe and up in America do you
[ __ ] see me more strong I feel it
more stronger fan bases in England
yeah just you're a period when I go over
there I'm least when I tour of it out
toward months so I'm Germany I just was
over did you where are you popular who
do you do these tours with I just did
the last one we're running drills but
usually I'll do every time I put out in
my odd tour in the States and then I go
overseas for a few months but yeah for
the most practice hit of Europe and
Germany you been everywhere pretty much
I've been Africa where that we went to
uh we went we did a thing with Adidas
and we went to Soweto whatever function
so well as I closed the slums like where
the Hudson [ __ ] at like he had us out
there NoHo Charles yeah we was into
hotels but they took us to the real [ __ ]
we went to the real Lions icing on lions
[Music]
but they did take its film we wrote four
wheelers to like the jungle that [ __ ]
was tight that was fun but I had a great
time up there though as flight was
longest [ __ ] though
okay I think it's like 18 hours maybe my
good I was drinking lean on the end of
our drinking sir Dean so uh I slept the
whole fight last time you drank away
[ __ ]
two or three years now damn you miss it
I mean it's like it but the type of
dream that I like they don't make no
more
so which one it was activist so once
that got discontinued I was like because
all the other [ __ ] really tastes like
cough syrup like activist was good that
[ __ ] was sweet that [ __ ] just was it was
addictive and they just stopped making
yeah cuz Justin Bieber ass they kept
catching Justin Bieber
retching room he was going crazy when
they raided his house and they found all
that sir for something so and they acted
this thing won't occur they be thinking
what if Justin Bieber [ __ ] the
overdose of this [ __ ] and they don't
want a [ __ ] on a name so they just
discontinue to serve but they do that
with or you know they do that with
druggie they come bring it back few
years later or change the name some so I
don't know I have I don't know he's
going on to sort of think it's about it
this [ __ ] his expensive man when he got
to the point when it was $100 a line
like [ __ ] that's when it was getting too
crazy and you spent it [ __ ] you
trying to buy [ __ ] you've got a I was
buying like 1/8 every two days and
that's like 800 hours of what a concert
for 8 ounces how much she was like yeah
he's because it got to the point 100 out
of the line
what's your line a line of the land okay
so every night I don't know I don't know
this term every line is the house you
know so saw a hundred hours for a wine
that's one sip
that's no you can put it you can most
people will put like you can put a line
in like a 20 ounce that'd be cool
but for the most part I at least put
most people would if a lot of people sip
and we'll put like a phone in a two
liter four ounces in between liter but
for most part like two I put two ounces
in to leave how long do you get [ __ ]
up for all night that one you keep calm
do you pass out on college you go
because your sir it says I've had before
the games is the first time you got help
on counters here
you didn't bring it over it was great
right forward up let me be poor love you
my got a cord up this episode of my
strange my favorite was pineapple fan
message is amazing or sprite remix the
clear spray that [ __ ] tastes amazing
don't get out I'm high in the [ __ ]
edibles yeah Jesus Christ I took like
one of those little [ __ ] two fives
annexes oh yeah but I can't watch the
[ __ ] news no more last night a plane
caught on fire yeah you know yeah man
like ex the engine I like to lose my
loft
no you know what man it's been [ __ ]
the bonds it's been the last year it's
just too [ __ ] political and then it's
bad news mm-hmm like it's never you know
I can live with some stuff the other day
I was watching a documentary I'm not
really a documentary like a miniseries
about that chick when I was a kid that
had the machine gun that went with the
army and then they robbed the bank the
white chick Patty and that [ __ ] you know
I that was the news when I was a kid
mm-hmm that was all right she was like a
millionaire and she got kidnapped by
this [ __ ] group and then they got
caught robbing a bank and people judged
whether or not she was doing it
voluntarily or she lost a mother I can
live with that that bad like I remember
sitting on the couch yeah are they
watching that I watched like two
episodes
and I saw myself as a child mm-hmm
eating dinner watching the new mm-hmm
and this was like The Biggest Loser
nobody was getting blown up nobody's
gonna show look at school
nobody was bad not in the [ __ ]
president nobody was you know asking
questions I'm back tonight it was just a
simple [ __ ] news world and now I
gotta open up with [ __ ] this and that
this guy didn't pull his gun then
[ __ ] this guy the Democrat you like
you don't want bro I was having a good
I want the pizza with the kids how good
of a time was I happy was I you were
born straws everywhere I was blowing
straws I had my daughter professionally
seen poplin Orangina I go to this ballet
right on Wednesdays I said I watched my
daughter glad Taysom I have a great time
I'm putting the show together and two of
the characters of the show the one bunny
whose dad is friends with mercy and dead
daughter and this is other dude that's
got to be six four five - Lena he's been
trying to lose weight for a while mm-hmm
he's got two gorgeous daughters he's got
one that you look at her at the eight
she's gotta be five and you know I gotta
get a [ __ ] shotgun pretty soon cuz
the mothers are not happen so she's
built like the mother and she's got a
big feet he's tall so she's got those
big feet like when you look at a puppy
and their feet it really knows he's
gonna beggin you like aw she's that me
and my wife were talking about you know
what he needs a shotgun for this little
girl my wife agrees you know what she
doesn't need a shotgun look at the
little sister the little sisters just as
pretty but she's built like the father
hmm
like a [ __ ] tank in there so she's
like her bodyguard what the father
reminds me who's the white dude that
produces all the rap we're rooting for
jay-z yeah that he you know brick movies
to go to town be strong hugger up I
believe a lot
really you know I'm not telling that
party yeah yeah
I never said two words - is he still
around he just put out I mean still he
got a list sometimes ojz out but it
wasn't bad yeah I like it
yeah you got a um he got his own record
label American record so who's what I
was the who's on he'd be producing for a
lot of rock people and [ __ ] - I not see
long ago like that like he always doing
like working with like legendary
[ __ ] like bringing them back
and [ __ ] I always forget to play jay-z
no we didn't forget to play jay-z well
that sounds great - good yeah the last
one
somebody tell somebody weird told me and
make sure I listen to it and it's on
YouTube when it was [ __ ] tremendous
for forty forty four forty psi like that
yeah yeah they really get it no it's
good good I mean for him to as many
projects as he's made consistently and
to do it again like that like I was I
was very impressed I thought you know
you know rap is it's oh no once it feel
like getting too many 40 but he I like
the fact that he's breaking it like he
can be the best 50 year old rapper you
can be the first one that could be 50
still doing it you know cuz most the
time they all that represents like that
you know
it's tough on the rapper otherside
fifty-first like I've seen the video of
prophets of rage and even what they're
doing that's exhausting yeah they're up
there [ __ ] work at a man that had
taken to the next [ __ ] level that's a
lot of work that's about when we had
that testosterone guy on to Belize but
one time I asked him who were your
biggest clients and he told me musician
mm-hmm he goes my biggest movie clients
right now at least 50 year old musician
to go on the road yeah they shoot the
testosterone that's crazy that's crazy
not sports not athletes they were his
biggest clients because think about
Harlem or both Sabbath was 60 and
they're out there doing every other
night mm-hmm
that's not bad
and they were doing three shows a week
and they knew it they knew by Friday
they were done in two days arrest and
they plan like two hours yeah hell hours
that's [ __ ] brutal man is brutal
listen I said the last week man I don't
know what it was it was the altitude you
know I sold out in Denver's only out of
the show again thank you
I definitely got mainly got in there was
time we ate we took naps we acclimate a
little I got up a little bit walking
around him snowing mm-hmm and I went I
did the two shows dong I went back to
the [ __ ] hotel I went to bed early
yeah yeah and dong I woke up the next
morning I don't know why I was always
[ __ ] heard like a truck hit me hmm
you know when I featured you don't give
a [ __ ] I've said this before you go away
and often there now is a headline in the
back of my mind you paid mm-hmm my whole
body's in the game like I'm it's
involved in that joke you don't say
there's nothing I'm Dane Cook I'm not
saying I'm jumping up and down them to
wait I can't do it no more
but your whole body has to feel the
intensity of the joke mm-hmm
you're feeling Lee in ten years you go
Wow way that you learn it that's
something you learn in time you know
that it's an experience in it that if
you're really throwing Heat you're
throwing heat from the [ __ ] sofa
your hearts beating you're playing the
game you're acting out the joke is
selling the joke
sometimes I go back little man my legs
are sore my stretches [ __ ] and take a
shower you know I give it up for those
older guys oh yeah man were on the road
[ __ ] playing Rudy Sarzo this really
starts with 66 of time [ __ ] still
goes out of the road still you know he
definitely gotta be this is crazy and
you know you guys are younger listening
when I was growing up when you were 50
they [ __ ] hung you out to dry his
lover it was over for you there was no
[ __ ] music career they shot you the
head the fact that these guys that's why
I'm [ __ ] bringing it out
because even technologies kept half
these guys alive
you know Ozzy Osbourne's should be dead
on normal paper I don't wish nobody that
I'm just telling you he's he's dead in
the party today I heard a story I'm
[ __ ] Ozzy's boneyard
I have mozzies boneyard I gotta have a
big baseball I got the seventies
eighties nineties and I got the one that
plays Soundgarden all the time yeah
that's my [ __ ] with you well I love
Eddie trunk that's my [ __ ] on
Mondays I listen to him he talks about
kisses [ __ ] why people he drives white
people crazy when he talks about kids I
think let me ask you something what have
you heard about Ace Frehley you know
he's [ __ ] hysterical
yeah I'll have you got to see your
brother oh yeah who came to Austin you
were [ __ ] gentlemen we will have to
eat yeah we had a good time you you're
you're bad [ __ ] I could open up
for you a few days yeah yeah I don't
want no money I just wanna you know give
you back someone to love you given the
show yeah yeah don't be dope and leave
what's going on with you I'm telling you
little ingrate yeah give me a piece of
mouth these are stronger than yeah they
get ta good but you gotta you don't know
the piece right now it's [ __ ]
Thursday night Winston how long so drink
I gotta go drink really yeah I got
you're drunk tonight yeah yeah you ready
to go you gonna Hollywood I'm gonna do
yeah so tomorrow night you want to go to
the High Times Awards all right wall go
right no distorted night all right nice
be drunk uh I have no [ __ ] idea what
time I'm doing part hands
what time you doing a packet or or
you'll have plenty I don't want to do a
spot come on I do I wanted to stop at a
fourth war what time is it right now you
know
dog already its own salon yeah now
they're [ __ ] done anyway listen you
don't need to have it for it to be
Valentine's Day to fall in love you
could fall in love whatever they you
can't get to know somebody by a profile
by looking at that picture we single now
I know he's been on eHarmony he's
looking around you know trying to meet
people is it easier with the eHarmony
Lee it's great and the signup process is
amazing so that really Europe matches
are a lot better then a lot of the other
side that we you seen so far you know
like I don't have that I don't have any
other outputs deleted every other out
recently so yeah it's the only one I use
oh he'll harmony is unlike many other on
like Dane side because he Amelie takes
steps and other dating sites wouldn't
even think about they're built to help
you find lasting meaningful relationship
not just a shallow hook-up site where
you meet in the whole town nobody knows
nothing and she's drunken you're drunk
Oh neither like next thing you know you
realize she's an escaped convict and a
husband's been looking at leas with the
cartel you don't need that aggravation
what I'm trying to say is they've helped
over a million people find their perfect
match he normally uses years and years
of science data and psychological
research to send you the right matches
nobody does that
he hardly brings compatible people that
get a thing about it how much longer can
you sit there and I list on the podcast
I mean there plenty of hookup sites out
there don't get me wrong everyone so why
I got to do it that we got to do but
this is not what he harmony is and what
I'm gonna do is this okay you're lonely
you want to give it a shot you know the
holiday hike this summer you want to
meet people right now right now you you
get a free month with eat harmony when
you sign up for a three-month
subscription what you need to do is
enter code Church at checkout so stop
waiting and start your journey to a
satisfying meaningful relationship I
mean it can be fun to play around when I
don't want to date in that Melissa
you gettin older you want responsibility
you want a family but most importantly
you want to fall in love with somebody
and have a meaningful relationship
there's one app built to bring your real
love and that's eHarmony come see how
differently harmony can be and how it
can change your life go to eHarmony calm
right now and get started enter code
Church at checkout I also want to thank
on it for always sending me taking care
of my mental state with half a brain and
shroom texture health and shroom tech
sport a sport and shroom tech onion I'm
sorry you don't say my memories fading
its 1053 at night I've been talking [ __ ]
for [ __ ] 10 hours delay anyway you
know how we do it here your bother to
try you don't like the alpha brain don't
send it back they still give you hundred
percent money-back guarantee who does
that the business nobody gonna calm
right now press in church yeah [ __ ] yeah
ten percent off right off the top
delivered to your house or will be here
at the end of March to talk to you
people about what he's doing that his
new book how's that for you and also
Fuji you're a fat [ __ ] you wanna train
but you don't know what to do let me
tell you something I've have a thousand
people give me ease and presence and
Fuji is the best for the fat guy because
if you're in somebody's guard and
they're trying to pull you down most go
most come telling you I had a gig from a
couple places they just rip especially
training in our Brno cranes because
those guys pull the [ __ ] sleeve my
Fuji Giza tip-top Magoo and their
quality and they're cheap and they're
[ __ ] door more dependable and if
you're a big guy go to Fuji Sports calm
right now and press Enter BAM and get
10% off on the house and [ __ ] and
tell'em uncle Joey sent you beside that
always a pleasure to have this guy this
guy's uh oh yeah this guy is gonna be
Smokey Robinson right he has the class
in the charisma
oh just something you know he's he's my
he's my new Ralphy Ezra he's my new
brother he's a good man he's solid and
if he come to your town make sure you
stay here and tell him the [ __ ]
Church century that's right my main man
obey he's a [ __ ] Savage the younger I
write at least say I was going on down
you gonna date this weekend oh
absolutely
mine wonky something a little Dave on
eHarmony you'll find yourself a me for
relationship absolutely do you just want
to play the field what happen so now I
mean I know yeah I know what you
predicted Danny Danny Brown knows and
then on March 10th obvious Sam Triple E
and a bunch of great people and Santa
Barbara so go check out an Instagram for
that that's like the Velvet Jones or
something I'm stylin Farley all right
well I want to thank you harmony I want
to thank of it I want to thank Fuji
Sports calm I want to thank my main man
Danny Brown thank y'all the most
important I want to thank you people
don't forget
March 10th the Ice House working out
Saturday night 7:30 no big [ __ ] deal
15 bucks I'm trying to put this special
together and then on the 21st it's just
a live show up there in Nyack New York
on a Wednesday night [ __ ] work on
Thursday and I love you [ __ ]
along my heart thank you for the emails
thank you for the support you know the
[ __ ] drill stay black stay safe have
a great weekend keep your eyes open
uncle Joey loves you kick that [ __ ]
mule Lee kick that mule a
[Music]